[Musique]
le parti du cinéma documentaire de
Maxime gronder et Pauline galinari ou
comment jusqu'au début des années 80 le
Parti communiste français avait choisi
de faire du cinéma un outil de
propagande d'un militantisme par l'image
qui n'a d'ailleurs pas été le seul à
utiliser loin de là on témoigne d'autres
productions communistes de par le monde
mais aussi de production hollywoodienne
sans qu'on y prenne toujours garde les
guerres froides entre état on passe en
réalité parfois par les salles obscures
et c'est de cette place de la propagande
politique sur le grand écran dont nous
allons débattre maintenant avec nos
invités en commençant par vous parce
qu'elle aurait eu bienvenue vous êtes
historien auteur spécialiste de
l'histoire sociale et culturelle
française contemporaine on vous doit
récemment qu'est ce qu'une nation une
histoire mondiale publiée chez Gallimard
Éric libio est également avec nous
bienvenue à vous et avec l'idiot vous
êtes journaliste ancien rédacteur en
chef du service culture de L'Express
spécialiste du cinéma vous êtes
aujourd'hui journaliste à lire et
chroniqueur à France Inter membre
également du comité de sélection du
Festival de Cannes dont on espère bien
sûr très fort qui va bel et bien se
tenir au printemps prochain et puis vous
êtes également auteur avec entre autres
de Clint et moi paru récemment chez
Jean-Claude latesse Clint il s'agit bien
sûr de Clint Eastwood qu'on voit sur la
couverture de votre livre et c'est donc
à découvrir chez Jean-Claude latesse on
va revoir tout de suite un premier
extrait du documentaire il s'agit du
lancement en 1936 de la Vie est à nous
de Jean Renoir
la première fois un parti politique
produit un long métrage dans des
conditions professionnelles avec
l'ambition de le diffuser dans les
salles de cinéma
ça peut pas continuer
pour le PCF c'est l'aboutissement d'un
processus engagé 15 ans plus tôt
en décembre 1920 le congrès socialiste
réunis à Tours s'achève sur une scission
le Parti communiste voit le jour
suivant le modèle soviétique tous les
moyens de propagande possible doivent
être utilisés le cinéma apparaît
d’emblée très approprié pour faire de
l'agitation politique
accessible à tous jouant sur une
illusion de réel et potentiellement
reproductible à l'infini c'est pour
Lénine le plus important de tous les
arts alors le Parti communiste
soviétique a décidé de faire du cinéma
un outil de propagande il le préconise
au parti frère et c'est comme cela que
le Parti communiste français s'engage
dans cette aventure du cinéma de
propagande c'est ce qu'on comprend dans
ce film c'est tout à fait exact il faut
préciser tout de suite pour élargir les
enjeux puisque ça va être le sens de ce
débat que Mussolini dit exactement la
même chose que Lénine presque dans les
mêmes années c'est à dire que les
nouveaux régimes modernes totalitaires
les dictatures mais modernes ont bien
compris que le cinéma on pourrait
ajouter bientôt la radio le disque etc
avec ses haut-parleurs dans tout ça
c'est la technologie de la dictature
de la propagande et c'est donc pour ça
qu'on voit arriver dans les salles
obscures c'est ces premières productions
du Parti communiste français Jean Renoir
c'est lui qui signe ce film autrement
dit il y a tout de même des réalisateurs
de renom qui vont s'engager dans cette
aventure parfois n'a pas fait grand
chose il l'a voulu être dans ses écrits
il a beaucoup fait travailler ses
assistants beaucoup plus que lui et que
le Parti communiste avait besoin d'un an
il y a eu après Louis Daquin qui était
aussi célèbre un peu moins que Renoir
Renoir sortait juste d'un film qui
s'appelait le crime de Monsieur l'ange
qui était un film sur la classe ouvrière
déjà sur la coopérative donc il avait
déjà un petit peu cette étiquette qui
lui était accolé et puis c'était un des
grands cinéastes des années 30 donc
effectivement le le PC a fait travailler
des des militants enfin des des
cinéastes des artistes qui qui étaient
évidemment dans leur outil dans leur
combat commun au PC à l'époque ils sont
vus regarder dans les salles de cinéma
ces films ou alors est-ce qu'ils sont
destinés et essentiellement vu des
militants communistes la vie est à nous
n'aura pas de visa de censure donc c'est
réservé ce qui va être le drame on le
dit bien dans le documentaire à
plusieurs reprises au moment de la
guerre froide etc de ces films c'est que
ils savent bien à l'avance qu'ils
n'auront pas le visa ou ils testent ils
l'ont pas et donc ça prêche ensuite des
convaincus alors rétrospectivement c'est
intéressant de voir qu'effectivement
Jacques Becker Jean-Paul Le Chat Noir
des gens qui vont faire carrière ont
commencé un peu sous l'égide du PC dont
il n'était pas forcément membres le
chanoa oui mais Jean Renoir non on l'a
très bien compris c'est aussi une
période c'est pas très marxiste de le
dire mais c'est tout à fait ça où il est
il a pour compagne Marguerite Marguerite
houlay qui est par sa famille proche du
Parti communiste et comme par hasard les
moments effectivement le crime de
Monsieur l'ange qui d'ailleurs est un
film plutôt un art justement mal vu par
le Parti communiste mais aussi Tony la
Marseillaise etc c'est le moment où
Renoir est le plus clairement cinéaste
de gauche comme par hasard c'est le
moment il est compagnon de Marguerite à
part une partie communiste français vous
voyez d'autres formations politiques
françaises qui se sont lancés dans une
telle aventure de propagande de cinéma
il y a quelques films de propagande de
la droite il y a un film justement à ce
moment-là de Léon Poirier qui est un
film de fiction sur le père de Foucault
donc on voit très bien que clairement un
film de droite catholique même presque
d'extrême droite et qui est le résultat
d'une souscription populaire comme la
Marseillaise donc c'est pas un film de
programme de partie il faut bien voir
que la gauche n'a pas l'exclusivité
d'ailleurs le Parti communiste non plus
parce qu'au moment du film de Renoir le
Parti socialiste il n'a pas les moyens
ou pas la volonté surtout d'aller
au-delà vers le long métrage le Parti
socialiste et ses fillot avec marsupiler
l’el-gauche du Parti socialiste fait des
contractualités cinématographiques aussi
on va voir un deuxième extrait du du
documentaire parce que il y a aussi on a
parlé de quelques réalisateurs qui ont
participé à cette aventure décrite dans
le film il y a aussi des des acteurs des
compagnons de route on va dire les
choses comme cela du PCF qui ont
participé à cette aventure
dans le monde du cinéma de nombreux
professionnels adhèrent au PCR pour
beaucoup ils sont également membres de
la CGT le syndicat majoritaire parmi les
techniciens du cinéma qui est largement
sous influence communiste
certains compagnons de route deviennent
rapidement célèbres dans l'après-guerre
comme Gérard Philipe Yves Montand encore
Simone Signoret
[Musique]
toutes les ce que j'ai Pascal les films
étaient quand même ils étaient diffusés
dans dans des écoles ou dans les mairies
ou c'était quand même des décisions des
diffusions extrêmement sommaires et que
financier oui c'était confidentiel ouais
voilà bon après ils avaient un réseau un
maillage de dans les villes le PC était
quand même dans une dans une forme
olympique à l'époque mais disons que les
les artistes même ou les cinéastes il a
fallu attendre le chat noir comme disait
Pascal il a fallu attendre que la
fiction vraiment prenne le relais de la
propagande pour que le commun des
mortels le public en général est accès à
ce en tout cas au discours pas forcément
aux films produits par le PC mais en
tout cas au discours que véhiculer ce
vous disiez tout à l'heure qu'il y a
beaucoup de réalisateurs qui ont
finalement un peu commencé leur carrière
à travers ces expériences du PCF c'est
le cas aussi pour les acteurs alors on
parle peut-être pas d'Yves Montand et de
Simone Signoret qui était déjà des stars
après hier il y a tout de même des
acteurs dont pour lesquels ça a été
marche-pied pas vraiment pour Michel
Piccoli parce que il va rebondir une
dizaine d'années plus tard donc ça ne
compte pas où ça ça se retourne presque
contre lui on pourrait ajouter le nom de
Gérard Philippe je veux dire par là que
vous avez des acteurs dont on sait bien
qu'ils ont le cœur à gauche et même
comme Gérard Philipe fils de collabo ça
aide peut-être ils ont leur carte donc
ça c'est un premier élément le deuxième
élément on a vu défiler Jean Marais
Madeleine Sologne etc contre les accords
blumbirds on va sans doute parler et
c'est une façon de mobiliser autour de
mot d'ordre du Parti communiste des gens
qui sont pas du tout communistes y
compris des producteurs de cinéma qui se
sentent menacés ou des exploitants de
sale bon et puis troisièmement peut-être
le plus important et ça a été dit la CGT
c'est à dire que jusqu'en 36 jusqu'au
graphe de 36 le cinéma n'est absolument
pas syndiqué les seuls secteurs
syndiqués c'est ce qui ressemble à une
industrie classique c'est à dire les
labos qui qui fabriquent de la pellicule
ou qui la transforme d'accord mais sur
les tournages vous avez pas un seul
syndiqué brutalement en 36 on passe de
quasiment 0% à quasiment 100% de
syndicalisation alors
prêt ça reversera mais il ne reste pas
moins que quand on dit CGT fédération du
spectacle après la guerre en réalité
c'est le parti communiste qui est
derrière ironiquement parlant le
président de la fédération du spectacle
à un certain moment s'appelle Claude
autant Lara qui terminera élu Front
national
à l'assemblée européenne donc les
évolutions sont diverses et variées mais
la CGT ça pèse et évidemment comme l'a
dit le documentaire à cette époque-là la
CGT c'est quand même très proche du
Parti communiste il y a une subtile
différence ou pas si subtile que ça vous
allez nous répondre entre le cinéma
engagé français et le cinéma de
propagande qu'on découvre dans ce film
aussi régulier c'est peut-être le moment
de le souligner ça oui disons que le
cinéma de propagande c'est plutôt un
cinéma institutionnel qui est produit
dirigé décidé par des institutions en
l'occurrence là le Parti communiste
français après un cinéma de propagande
le cinéma hollywoodien est ainsi les
maths de propagande aussi alors que il y
a pas la tête de d'Hollywood des gens
qui décidaient c'est juste que une façon
pour Hollywood de véhiculer le système
de de vie mais il y a aussi américain
parce qu'on va reparler bien sûr du de
cette production hollywoodienne dans un
instant il y a aussi un cinéma engagé
français estampillé comme tel et qui et
qui a pu connaître un vrai succès à
travers différentes offres dans les
salles françaises oui bonjour a tendance
à dire que tout l'art ou le cinéma est
engagé de toute manière il y a un
discours à la base forcément alors
évidemment on est passé on est passé
d'un système institutionnalisé comme
comme la production du PCF à des films
de fiction disons que le public voulait
vous pouvez voir un samedi soir mais le
discours le discours est toujours les
auteurs défendent quelque chose de toute
manière même Louis Daquin défend la
position communiste mais de d'autres
cinéastes défendent autre chose enfin
une vision du monde en tout cas donc
c'est toujours très très la frontière
est très maigre entre entre mince entre
propagande et polyester de ma politique
c'est voilà les choses se mélangent
assez facilement quand même dans ce film
on n'a pas grand chose un petit peu mais
sur les guerres de décolonisation
française
l'Indochine l'Algérie or il y a eu une
production française qui est arrivée
après le déroulement de ces deux guerres
en revanche le Parti communiste a l'air
de s'être assez peu engagé sur sur ce
terrain et pourtant le PCF militait
fortement pour l'indépendance à la fois
en Indochine et en Algérie et un passage
sur la Tunisie plus tard la guerre du
Vietnam mais on sent bien que les
auteurs les réalisateurs sont presque un
peu marginalisés par le PC qui est quand
même un parti qui a été deux
gouvernement à la Libération qui certes
est repassé dans l'opposition mais qui a
clairement engagé contre la gardiens
d'Indochine parce que face à la France
puis aux Américains ce sont des
communistes qui se battent dans la
guerre d'Algérie c'est plus compliqué
c'est plus compliqué le FLN n'est pas
communiste donc il y a des allées venus
et il y a des gens comme René Vautier
qui sont un certain moment communistes
mais qui passe vraiment côté FLN et là
ils vont d'une certaine façon trop loin
du point de vue communiste donc là ce
sont des individus ce qu'on voit bien
dans des films qui qui prennent la
tangente et à ce moment là ils perdent
ils perdent de parti communiste c'est là
où on voit la limite du jour c'est à
dire qu'à un moment donné c'est Sydney à
cela on a envie d'être cinéaste ils
n'ont plus envie d'être aux ordres du PC
ils ont vu ils ont envie d'affirmer leur
propre vision du monde leurs propres
qualités d'artistes et effectivement en
Vautier est un bon exemple quand vous
voyez va attendre les horaires ou
d'autres films comme ça qui
effectivement s'éloignent des positions
du PC mais affirme une qualité
cinématographique que les productions du
PC n'avaient sans doute pas à un moment
donné c'est l'artiste qui prend aussi le
devant avec tout ce qui comporte comme
comme identité personnelle comme message
comme vision politique etc mais c'est
l'artiste qui prend le pas sur le
militant si je puis dire on va passer un
troisième extrait du documentaire il
s'agit des fameux accords bloombirds
vous en avez parlé il y a un instant et
Dieu sait s'ils sont importants pour le
cinéma français ces accords
au printemps 1946 les gouvernements
français et américains signent des
accords économiques ont une annexe
concerne au cinéma ce sont les accords
Bloomberg
interdit sous l'Occupation les films
américains peuvent désormais être
importés en France sans restriction
entrée au PCF pour résister pendant la
guerre le réalisateur Louis d'Aquin
devient le cinéaste du parti dans
l'après-guerre à la tête du syndicat CGT
des techniciens du film il est aux
avant-postes du combat à venir
l'Amérique avait produit beaucoup de
films pendant la guerre
que nous nous en avions produits très
peu et ça aurait été vraiment l'invasion
du marché français par le Seigneur
américain ça ça a été une très belle
bataille qui s'est livré
[Musique]
soutenant les comités de défense du
cinéma français la CGT et le PCF relais
et amplifient les revendications tout en
les utilisant pour dénoncer
l'impérialisme américain alors ça c'est
un combat du Parti communiste français
avec ces fameuses accords
bloombirds alors évidemment un Bloom
c'est Léon Blum qui négociait pour la
France et puis burn c'est jumper qui
était secrétaire d'État de Truman à
l'époque il s'agit donc si on a bien
compris de contingenté
l'arrivée du cinéma américain dans les
salles obscures françaises d'une part et
puis d'essayer de taxer ce cinéma
américain pour essayer d'alimenter la
production française c'est la création
du CNC du fameux CNC et ce sont les
prémices de ce qui existe maintenant
chez nous en France toujours maintenant
chez nous en France pour préserver notre
production nationale c'est très
important cet accord oui parce que une
sorte de fable typiquement française du
volontarisme de l'État parce que c'est
quand même l'état relayer d'ailleurs par
les débats à l'Assemblée nationale très
violents sur les accords bloombirt mais
attention il y a un mythe premièrement
dans le CNC existe déjà depuis quelques
temps il va intervenir en fin en fin de
course pour soutenir évidemment pour
recevoir en quelque sorte le fond de
soutien qui est le début de l'esquisse
de la politique qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui qui est extraordinairement
sophistiqué d'aide au cinéma la France
est un modèle la Corée du Sud inspire
parce que on va on va très loin on est
d'ailleurs ceux qui sont ceux qui sont
allés le plus loin dans l'aide au cinéma
et ça commence en réponse aux accords
Bloom Burns les accords bloombirs
c'est des accords généraux qui sauvent
la mise à l'économie française avant les
deux raisons le président
et vous ça concerne les céréales etc et
puis vous avez un avenant de la dette
des avances américaines et c'est le
fameux plan Marshall finalement
il n'est pas encore en place donc il y a
urgence il y a le feu au lac et donc il
y a un avenant de rien du tout mais là
les gens de cinéma
le découvre qui concerne le cinéma or
Burns dans la vie civile c'est j'ose
dire il est il a été il restera l'avocat
d'Hollywood des grandes majeurs donc
comme par hasard mais c'est tout à fait
normal aux États-Unis vous circulez du
prix au public il y a aucun problème
c'est même plutôt la bonne idée vous
êtes félicité pour ça et évidemment
cette avenant favorise alors attention
c'est pas l'invasion c'est simplement un
abaissement d'Équateur qui permet plus
facilement au cinéma américain de se
retrouver sur les sur les grands écrans
des salles il était déjà très présent
avant guerre de toute façon mais c'est
facilité mais c'est pas pardon c'est un
grand paradoxe une histoire assez
formidable parce qu'effectivement le PC
c'est dit c'était un peu pour lutter
contre l'invasion du cinéma américain
effectivement sur chaque billet et
encore aujourd'hui d'ailleurs il y a un
pourcentage qui est sur tous les films
qui qui sont diffusés donc américain
argentins français bien évidemment ça ça
vient de là il y a de l'argent qui est
ponctionné sur chaque billet qui est
remis dans le pot comme dit Pascal c'est
un système très vertueux et c'est vrai
que le PC à l'époque il voulait un petit
peu contrecarrer l'impérialisme
américain or ils ont été complètement
quand même
submergé parce qu'on quand on a vu en 46
tous ces films arrivés on a vu les
filets les films de Billy Wilder les
fins le film noir ce qu'on a appelé le
film noir c'est sa date de cette époque
là et ils ont vu arriver le Faucon
Maltais assurance sur la mort Laura tous
tous ces grands films à un moment donné
les spectateurs français ont pris ça
dans dans dans les yeux et puis ça a été
le cinéma américain c'est imposé de fait
alors qu'au départ c'était un peu pour
lutter et on s'est rendu compte que et
bien évidemment aux États-Unis c'était
facile de tourner pendant la guerre
puisqu'il y avait ils étaient pas le
pays n'est pas envahi donc ils ont
continué à produire et puis les grands
chefs-d'œuvre de la comédie et du film
noir parce que c'est vraiment à cette
époque là entre entre 30 et 55 que ce
genre là a fleuri et bien tous ces films
là sont arrivés en France et on s'est
rendu compte de
importance de qualitative de cinéma
américain et la mythologie américaine
même si effectivement comme dit Pascal
le cinéma américain était très populaire
avant guerre mais a vraiment pris de
l'ampleur à cette époque là entre entre
45 jusqu'à aux années 70 sur cette
partie de l'accord bombers vous l'avez
rappelé c'est une infime partie ce qui
concerne le cinéma il est dit dans ce
documentaire que le PCF a beaucoup pesé
c'est la réalité ou c'est un petit peu
vous avez plus de réserve sur ce que dit
dans ce documentaire sur le poids du PCF
sur le fond de cet accord et l'obtention
de cet accord vous avez noté la date des
accords à cette époque là les
communistes sont au gouvernement sauf
que très vite ils en sont ils ont chassé
un peu les cas c'est incompatible avec
la guerre froide qu'il reste dans le
gouvernement et à ce moment-là il se
redonne une virginité d'opposite
d'opposant puis alors ce qui est très
fort c'est qu'ils ont derrière eux là
les producteurs français les exploitants
sont partagés parce que les exploitants
eux un bloc Buster comme on dit
aujourd'hui américain il s'en arrange
mais alors les producteurs les
distributeurs son vent debout évidemment
les acteurs la CGT sont vend debout
contre l'invasion américaine donc c'est
tout bénéfice pour le parti communiste
et c'est maintenant tout bénéfice pour
le cinéma français parce que la réponse
passée par le gouvernement et d'abord
par l'Assemblée nationale de l'époque
puisque le Sénat à l'époque de la fin du
Conseil de la République joue pas un
grand rôle ça a été le fond d'aide quand
même oui recette créée par Malraux
c'est la continuité quand même de cet
accord là de 46 l'avancée recette de
Malroy qui a lieu en 50 c'est introduit
du qualitatif alors que là c'est
automatique effectivement comme le dit
Eric vous achetez votre billet pour voir
un film américain et bah vous contribuez
au financement et aujourd'hui encore
c'est génial c'est pour ça que beaucoup
de pays étrangers sont inspirés alors
malgré ces accords ces fameuses accords
Lombards c'est vrai que le cinéma
américain le cinéma hollywoodien est
arrivé en force dans les salles
françaises a fait beaucoup d'entrées et
avec ce fameux soft power américain dont
on parle beaucoup qui est une forme de
propagande qui ne dirait pas son nom
c'est comme ça qu'il faut comprendre
cette fameuse expression du soft power
de la production voilà c'est ça c'est
c'est des films qui s'affichent pas
comme militant mais qui raconte un mode
de vie qui raconte un pays une politique
une société et donc une manière de vivre
un art de vivre si on prend du point de
vue positif oui voilà c'est ça et dès
1905 faire le cinéma 1 au tout départ
les frères Lumière pardon de cette
petite parenthèse c'était du témoignage
journalistique ils sont allés ils ont
fait du documentaire et puis après il y
a eu l'Amérique qui tout d'un coup c'est
dit mais on peut aussi raconter des
histoires on peut aussi prendre des
personnages la fiction des drames etc et
Hollywood a été bâti à la fois sur ce
désir de romanesque sur un système
économique extrêmement sophistique enfin
sophistiqué en tout cas très très
positif et puis
l'idée qu'à un moment donné on va
pouvoir les États-Unis ils vont pouvoir
répondre sur le sur le monde ce qu'ils
ont fait d'ailleurs
leur
impérialisme culturel c'est ça c'est le
soft power américain et aujourd'hui
encore même si c'est un peu mis à mal
peut-être par des productions nationales
qui sont devenues de plus en plus
importantes et aussi par la le phénomène
des plateformes mais
pendant plus de 100 ans c'est le cinéma
américain qui a régné sur les écrans
avec le fameux cocktail action aventure
humour amour et puis effets spéciaux
c'est ce fameux cocktail et puis le
blockbusters américains la civilisation
américaine est née avec le cinéma c'est
à dire que le l'Amérique et le cinéma
c'est du direct quand quand il y a la
guerre du Vietnam puisque c'est aussi de
la propagande enfin ou de l'anti
propagande ou de la critique politique
et bien il raconte tout de suite nous en
France on a mis pour les l'Algérie des
années avant de parler d'Algérie
apocalypnose et en 74 en 78 enfin tous
ces films en petits vietnamien se porte
c'était pendant la guerre du Vietnam
donc les Américains utilisent le cinéma
systématiquement pour expliquer leur
façon d'être leur façon de vivre et ça a
été des voilà dès le début du siècle
donc une façon oui de propagande on peut
le résumer parler d'une propagande
initiée par la production hollywoodienne
on peut utiliser ce mot oui parce que si
vous voulez le système on va l'appeler
capitaliste américain tellement fort que
ça ira dit de la propagande presque
naturellement c'est ce que expliqué Eric
et à tel point que par exemple en France
il faut que l'État intervienne pour
censurer là Hollywood le grand danger ce
serait que l'État fédéral l'État fédéral
c'est toujours d'actualité regardez
Trump l'État fédéral mettre son nez dans
les affaires d'Hollywood donc au niveau
de l'État fédéral nous ferons
l'ascension nous-même ce sera le code
ice et ils font leur propre gendarmerie
donc c'est très c'est très fort c'est
c'est moi caricatural mais il y a
quelques films américains bon laissons
même de côté des petits films de
propagande en pleine guerre froide mais
par exemple Mister Smith au Sénat 1939
c'est un film extraordinaire à l'éloge
quand même de la démocratie américaine
il y a il y a un peu plus d'un an à
Orléans on a reconstitué le Festival de
Cannes en présence d'Eric qui n'a pas eu
lieu 193 le premier et oui il était
prévu de projeter ce film il était même
prévu de projeter du côté soviétique
Alexandre Nevski bon au dernier moment
les Soviétiques ont retiré les sandwski
chercher pourquoi bon vaste problème
mais il y avait Mr smithena et on a fait
un vote il y a un peu plus d'un an à
Orléans c'est c'est le film de capral Mr
Smith au Cénac qui a remporté la Palme
d'Or introspective parce que c'est un
film extraordinaire qu'il faut voir à
mon avis en ce moment au moment où Biden
succède à Trump alors vous parlez de
Capra j'ai lu quelque part en préparant
cette émission que il était un moment
dans le bureau de Roosevelt instant 1942
avec dun Ford et Roosevelt leur vient
demander de mettre leur talent au
service de la mobilisation psychologique
du pays c'est le fameux cinéma
patriotique américain aussi oui il y a
eu quand même pendant la guerre qui
était le pendant de ce qu'on a vu au PC
aux États-Unis pourquoi nous combattants
qui est quand même pour que nous
combattons pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et John Ford est capras et tout
si c'est signe là ont filmé ou ont
expliqué on fait de la propagande
diffusée dans les salles de cinéma pour
expliquer le point de vue américain et
pourquoi est-ce que est-ce que les
États-Unis se sont engagés dans la
guerre donc là on a vu aussi la
production de du Parti communiste
français pendant la fameuse guerre
froide cette guerre froide elle est bel
et bien eu lieu dans dans les cinémas
dans les salles de cinéma à travers les
productions cinématographiques de
l'époque plutôt dans les milieux du
cinéma en particulier aux États-Unis
avec le black la mise sur liste noire le
blacklista la commission McCarthy etc
donc effectivement il y a une chasse aux
sorcières à Hollywood même ça c'est un
absolument contestable donc c'est
presque la pointe avancée mais là c'est
moins la propagande que la j'allais dire
la sangsue il y a une grande production
pendant la guerre froide elle-même dans
les années 50-60 jusque l'arrivée de
Reagan par exemple l'arrivée de Reagan
au début des années 80 elle correspondu
à ce qu'on a appelé le cinéma des gros
bras c'est-à-dire de Stallone de cinéma
Rambo
1 2 3 voilà Rambo depuis tous les films
de schwarzen qui réaffirmé c'est le
cinéma patriotique américain de l'air
végan c'est l'idée de dire on réaffir
notre position de gendarmes de monde les
gros bras c'est nous et les gros bras
physiquement c'était eux enfin c'était
même pas une métaphore c'est quand on
l'a envoyé alors le Rambo 1 était un
film critique sur le sur la sur la
guerre du Vietnam mais dès le rend beau
2 3 4 là on était beaucoup plus sur le
sur
l'invasion que la critique de l'invasion
soviétique en Afghanistan donc dans ces
années là donc c'est très proche de nous
ça a 35 ans 40 ans le cinéma
hollywoodien était toujours un cinéma de
propagande alors là c'est plus
l'americanofly mais c'est vraiment on
s'affirme comme les gendarmes du monde
puisque à l'est le mur s'est effondré
donc il y a une classe à prendre et la
place à prendre bah ce sont les gros
bras qui vont les prendre il faut lire
cette histoire du cinéma aussi à l'aune
de ça alors en même temps on voit que à
l'époque de Donald Trump les relations
étaient mauvaises avec Hollywood quand
même Trump détestait Hollywood c'est à
dire pour pour lui c'était quand même
trop à gauche
c'était trop libre donc voilà oui il a
toujours été Hollywood a toujours été
beaucoup plus démocrate peut-être pas
les patrons de studio qui qui
affirmaient
qui assurait le capitalisme mais mais
tout le côté artistique on sait que
Steven Spielberg par exemple est un des
plus grands donateurs financiers du du
Parti démocrate et on l'a bien vu les
diatribe entièrement anti Trump il y a 4
ans contre pas été élu c'était Hollywood
qu'il a qu'il a nourrit quand même alors
il y a une autre guerre froide auquel on
assiste aujourd'hui ou peut-être une
double guerre froide États-Unis Chine et
puis peut-être encore États-Unis Russie
États-Unis Chine la Chine c'est devenu
le plus gros marché mondial de
l'industrie du cinéma depuis l'année
dernière depuis 2020
c'est un bras de fer qui se joue aussi
dans les oui alors c'est une
Ping a compris assez rapidement que pour
flatter le nationalisme
chinois ou peut-être pour éteindre les
critiques et bien il fallait un petit
peu susciter comme ça l'AD et le cinéma
chinois qui potentiellement
effectivement un bassin de public énorme
à lancer des productions très
nationalistes très historiques pour pour
la gloire du de la Chine mais on
remarque que très très peu de films
c'est pour ne dire aucun sorte de des
frontières chinois en tout cas il y a
c'est pas qu'ils veulent pas sortir des
frontières chinoises c'est qu'il y a pas
de distributeur il y a pas de pays qui
veulent l'acheter considérant sans doute
que la qualité n'est peut-être pas au
rendez-vous mais c'est une façon donc
c'est c'est uniquement au marché interne
qu'il est qu'il est qui s'adresse mais
c'est aussi une façon pour pour la Chine
pour le gouvernement de de flatter et
puis de dire que voilà on est les
premiers on existe etc etc mais la
production américaine elle rentre elle
est bien dans les salles de cinéma
chinoises à certaines conditions
visiblement notamment il faut éviter les
trois tiens parler de Taïwan du Tibet
des manifestations tiennent elles-mêmes
puis il y a d'autres thèmes à bannière
pour les producteurs qui seraient tentés
par le marché chinois la tentative du
président
de prolonger évidemment infiniment
indéfiniment son mandat ou encore la
détention et la torture des des Ouigours
mais enfin si on contourne tous ces
obstacles on a une chance de rentrer sur
le marché chinois lorsqu'on produit des
cinémas à Hollywood d'aujourd'hui sans
problème on voit que ces conditions sont
pas contradictoires avec le
développement d'un soft power américain
parce que franchement les Wiggs ça sera
peut-être l'obsession de d'Hollywood
mais trois remarques premièrement vous
citer à juste titre Russie et Chine deux
pays dont l'un est toujours
officiellement communiste et l'autre à
sa tête monsieur Poutine qui vient de le
KGB donc il y a quand même une
continuité avec l'agit propre de
deuxième remarque effectivement vous
avez raison et fille historique
c'est-à-dire plus généralement quel que
soit le pays du monde quand on met en
avant des films à costumes le discours
politique et en particulier et souvent
très fort et troisièmement moi c'est mon
souvenir de mes séjours en Chine c'est
la télévision chinoise qui diffuse ce
genre de film ou des séries télé qui qui
sont d'un nationalisme mais vraiment à
l'ancienne alors là la dimension
internationale
n'existe plus vraiment on a affaire à un
nationalisme chinois comme on a à faire
un nationalisme russe aujourd'hui d'où
la récupération de Staline vous savez
par la propagande de Poutine parce que
Staline c'est la grande guerre pas de
triotique le marxisme dans tout ça donc
on peut parler d'un cinéma de propagande
de d'État en Chine et peut-être en
Russie aujourd'hui en Chine c'est passé
en trois phases hein la première c'était
la critique des cinémas d'auteurs enfin
l'étouffement du cinéma d'auteur
jean-guymou par exemple qui est venu à
Cannes mais ce qui ce cinéma là ne
produisait que des films de festivals un
peu vu d'un mauvais œil par par le
gouvernement et bon il s'est un petit il
laissait faire donc ça c'était la
première étape la deuxième c'était on
ouvre un peu les les frontières au
cinéma étrangers et en l'occurrence le
cinéma américain pour un petit peu
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait dire ça
habituer le public à aller au cinéma et
puis en demandant aux Américains en fait
attention à ce qu'on épi troisième c'est
à partir du moment où le public chinois
était habitué enfin trouvé que c'était
très distrayant c'était formidable et
tout ça la production chinoise est
arrivée avec des films effectivement
nationalistes et aujourd'hui
c'est le pays c'est le pays où le le
public est le plus important mais
beaucoup plus avec des films des films
de propagande de nationalisme donc
c'était la troisième étape ils ont
essayé les Chinois ont gagné ils
produisent leur film ils le montrent au
public et le public applaudit
c'est des films qu'on peut voir
aujourd'hui sur des plateformes vous
parliez de plateformes de ce type de
violence c'est de nous faire une forme
de diffusion du cinéma qui a pris une
ampleur considérable qui plus est dans
la dans la crise sanitaire que nous
traversons on peut trouver des films
patriotiques nationalistes dont vous
parlez à la fois russe et chinois sur
les les plateformes en question il y a
aussi une guerre
de propagande sur ces plateformes
aujourd'hui entre les différentes
productions existant jusqu'à présent le
nerf de la guerre c'était effectivement
la diffusion on a dit un peu tout à
l'heure et donc les salles c'était
difficile de voir à partir du moment où
il y a aucun distributeur
argentin français américain qui veulent
qui qui veut prendre un film chinois ben
c'est difficile ou quasiment impossible
de les voir évidemment sauf à en être
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui avec les
plateformes c'est un peu différent alors
les films chinois
c'est un peu toujours un petit peu
compliqué tandis que les films le riz
sont on finit sur Netflix par exemple il
y a fonction d'autres plateformes il y a
des films alors les films soviétiques
aujourd'hui de propagande ce sont des
fils un petit peu ce qui était le cinéma
américain
c'est un petit peu ce que c'était le
cinéma dans ton parler de Reagan
c'est-à-dire des films de
science-fiction des gros bras les héros
nationalistes qui sauvent le monde etc
donc ils ont pris un peu le relais de
l'Amérique enfin en tout cas ils se sont
rendus compte que que d'affirmer le
héros soviétique c'était une bonne chose
pour la politique parce qu'à l'abri ça
sera ma dernière question on peut
imaginer qu'un autre parti politique
demain soit tenté par une aventure
propagandiste entre guillemets sur le
cinéma français ou alors c'est c'est une
époque révolue aucune époque n'est
revenu a priori parce qu'on est surpris
des retours moi je dirais que est-ce que
c'est le film qui avait qui serait
investi peut-être la série peut-être des
formes plutôt de l'audiovisuel que du
film
de fiction franchement c'est un peu
lourd comme investissement il y a
d'autres moyens de diffuser la
propagande par les réseaux sociaux vous
allez faire et donc il y a une dimension
un peu YouTube là en revanche vous avez
des choses assez étonnantes qui passent
sur des chaînes comme youtube mais alors
c'est en dessous de la ligne de
flottaison de la censure habituelle
qu'on peut on peut pas empêcher ça
diffusion un grand merci vraiment à tous
les deux devoir participé à ce débat doc
aujourd'hui consacrer vous l'avez
compris la propagande politique au
cinéma vos réactions à cette émission
sont attendues sur hashtag des Badoc
bien sûr sur Twitter et puis moi je vous
donne rendez-vous pour un prochain débat
doc ça sera bien sûr à la même place à
la même heure et toujours avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]